humana and canoe health want to remind
the community how important it is
to maintain a positive patient and
primary care provider relationship
here's rocky with more you guys are
working together to help people
understand
you know how to have a better
relationship with their primary care
physicians now right
yes exactly so sarah let's start with
you what exactly is a pr
primary care provider and how do you
maintain a positive relationship with
them
it's a great question so your primary
care provider or also known as a pcp
and really think of them as your home
base so they're the person that you go
to first with any preventative
screenings
any medical illnesses that might come up
non-urgencies
things that will keep you healthy and
then they're also going to be that point
person to give you any referrals that
are needed to get you out to a
specialist when needed
you should feel comfortable when you're
talking with your provider
when you come into any of the kano
offices we really like to focus on
serving our patients in their preferred
language understanding their culture
so if you are a spanish speaker tagalog
speaker many others
we have a full staff including providers
that can work with you and understand
some of those cultural differences
as well as the language barrier that
might exist
so that's one way to tell and then also
we want to make sure that
you're comfortable in getting the
information you need with medication
refills with your referrals that you
know that you're being taken care of
and if you don't feel that way when
you're talking with your doctor
it's a good time to assess that
relationship and see if it's the right
fit for you
perfect and rachel i'm going to have you
chime in here now um for our viewers who
are actually enrolled in medicare
how should they start that it's
important to express your intentions
make it clear that you want to be an
equal participant in the decision-making
process
and when it comes to making the most of
your visits there are certainly things
you can do to ensure
that your visits go smoothly here's my
checkup checklist
first review your family health history
ahead of your appointment
have your close relatives experienced
any new conditions or diseases since
your last visit
second write down a list of issues and
questions to take with you
have you noticed any body changes pain
or fatigue
have your eating or sleeping habits
changed are you taking your medications
as directed
be honest with yourself and your primary
care provider
and finally when you're at your
appointment discuss your future
review any scheduled treatments for
recent lifestyle changes
so you can help make more informed
decisions about your health care plan
write down notes so you can keep your
doctor's advice at hand once you get
back home
and if you do these things you're likely
not only impressed your provider
you may improve your likelihood of
getting the care that best meets your
needs
wow
i know right thank you thank you rachel
and sarah for you
any last words for our viewers that want
to know more about humana and just
how to take care of themselves overall
i'll add this at humana we not only care
for our medicare advantage members we
care about them too
this is the heart of our whole person
health care philosophy
and value-based care model that many of
our network providers participate in
primary care providers with the
value-based care arrangement
in our network are rewarded for care
that leads to better health and a better
experience for our patients
not just the number of patients they see
and the procedures they
order give humana a call at
1-800-345-8017 or
visit them online at healthfatcares.com